voici maintenant la caméra d'or qui
récompense un premier long métrage
j'appelle pour le remettre la
réalisatrice suisse président du jury de
la caméra d'or ursula meier
[Musique]
bonsoir le jury de la caméra d'or dont
je voudrais remercier sincèrement les
membres du jury ce soir tiens à dire que
nous avons vu de nombreux films qui nous
ont impressionnés vraiment par leur
audace par leur force cinématographique
nous avons fait le choix de distinguer
un premier long métrage qui a su allier
une immense délicatesse et une puissance
un film qui murmure et fait résonner une
voix singulière indissociable de son
interprète extraordinaire l'histoire
d'un corps qui se libèrent qui nous
libère la caméra d'or est attribuée à
girl de lukas donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est alors remercier tous ceux qui
m'ont entouré pendant le tournage je
suis comme faisait tellement deux
personnes montées
j'ai pu faire ce qu'aimer fine équipe se
réduit donc il mérite de daltonisme mon
équipe de nous mêler les acteurs qui ont
pu faire de peur de films devenus fous
tu tiens à dédier ce film à des
personnes exceptionnelles sans lesquels
ce qui n'existe pas d'abord une jeune
fille nora qui a été l'inspiration de ce
film à l'âge de 15 ans a décidé qu'elle
a il nous les têtes raides danseuse a
choisi sa propre identité
on serre et contre tout j'étais une
héroïne à l'épée
j'espère que c'est la vôtre aujourd'hui
la deuxième personne c'est celle qui a
obtenu ce rôle et qui est à côté de moi
sauf sexy ngo les personnes de 16 ans il
ya tenu ce rôle sans se soucier du qu'en
dira-t-on avec une maturité une élégance
absolument époustouflante est passé de
la reçu le booker il ya l'interprétation
[Applaudissements]
un prix donné son genre justement que
nous avons fait ce film et je suis
touché plus belles du tabac raconte avec
une influence limitée à transition à 15
heures une jeune fille plonge en
redonnant encore de garçon qui rêve de
devenir danseuse étoile son acteur
principal de recueil steurs obtenu hier
le prix d'interprétation du jury un
certain regard le film sortira le 10
octobre
il a aussi obtenu la pierre palm
[Musique]